my name is Andrew cuenta men and I'm an
assistant professor of Religious Studies
in the Department of Religious Studies
at Yale University and I work on the
Buddhist traditions of Tibet and
Himalayas we're here today in the by
Nicki Rare Book and Manuscript library
it is a place that has a very wonderful
collection of Tibetan and Himalayan
woodblock prints and manuscript texts
but they also have a really wonderful
collection of portable Tibetan religious
scroll paintings called Tong codes so
we'll be looking at some of those
paintings here today tanka is a Tibetan
portable religious painting it's a
scroll painting so it could be rolled up
and easily transported subject matters
are almost always religious in nature
Tonka painting could be commissioned by
high Lama for ritual purposes or it
could be commissioned by an ordinary
family in the event of a death in the
family for another kind of religious
purpose so painting our religious
painting was a great act of Merit making
in in traditional Buddhist societies
Tibetan tanka paintings vary greatly in
terms of subject matter in style
iconography and the kinds of figures
that they depict but there are certain
key elements that are common to almost
all Tibetan tanka paintings so first the
central painting would be prepared on
canvas canvas was usually white cotton
that was framed in a stretcher a kind of
gesso was applied to it then the painter
would usually lay out the econometrica
so the kind of framework of grid lines
and the outline of the central figures
the deities or the Buddha those lines
would then be overlaid with paint or ink
so the outlining was done first and then
gradually the colors would be added
usually first the background and then
the details of the figure and then
finally the face would be done the eyes
and the guild work so most tanka
paintings actually have a kind of liquid
gold that's applied to them but once the
painting was finished that was really
only the first part of the
struction of a Tonka painting the canvas
would be taken off of its stretcher and
then would be set within a complex
brocade frame so most Tonga's like this
one have an interior framework with
several kinds of alternating color broke
aids and then that was set within a
larger brocade frame and then at the top
and the bottom they usually had wood
bars that would help to stretch the
Tonka so that it would lay flat while
hanging on the arm and you can see on
the bottom here there are ornamental
ends that were usually placed on the
wooden bar and then finally there was a
curtain that was attached to the top of
the Tonka that could be raised up when
the tonk I needed to be displayed either
for ritual ceremonies or even if it was
just being left open in a shrine but if
the painting needed to be transported or
protected in some way then the curtain
could be lowered and that would protect
the painting from the elements from
sunlight or dirt or dust or things like
that so Tibetan painting is generally
rigidly defined traditional Tibetan
painters had a little leeway in terms of
korea expressing their own kind of
creativity so what this means is that
the detailed figures the deities the
buddha figures had proportions that were
clearly delineated within texts and so
one of the painters first tasks would be
to sort of translate the econometrics
that were transmitted in texts into
visual form and so every figure
including the figure of a Buddha that
you see here would have its proportions
sort of rigidly laid out and so a
Tibetan painter would lay out a series
of grid lines that would determine the
proportion of the face to the body and
the body torso to the overall figure it
would guide the painter and where to
place the eyes or other important Akeno
graphic features of a Buddha such as the
cranial bump called the huge nisha on
his head there were also strict
descriptions of the kinds of hand
gestures called mudras or the physical
pop body postures or like postures
called asanas these were also clearly
laid
out in texts so once the econometrics
for the central figure was laid out and
the secondary figures were late were
laid out then the painter had some
flexibility in terms of how he laid out
the background and that could in some
instances include kind of narrative
stories like we see in this painting
here or it could include kind of
environmental features things like
mountains or streams or sky and things
like that and that was really the realm
in which the artist had great license to
express his own creativity so this
painting was a gift to the by Nicki
library from Edna Breyer schwab in 1967
and it was probably part of a set we
have at least one other painting that
was part of this set and the central
figure is the historical buddha
shakyamuni buddha and the scenes around
it described a collection of his past
lives called Jatakas now the Jatakas
were a really important form of Buddhist
literature they are found in Buddhist
traditions across Asia in the Pali Canon
in the Tibetan and Chinese cannons as
well there were hundreds of different
Jataka stories and there were several
which were really important in Tibet and
this is one of those stories so the
central image here is the historical
buddha shakyamuni and he's shown in a
kind of traditional form he seated
cross-legged on a lotus throne and the
lotus is supported by a throne held up
by force no lines very traditional
Tibetan motif you'll see that he sitted
with crossed legs and his left hand is
held in meditation posture it holds a
begging bowl here looks like it's filled
with flowers in his right hand is held
in the mudra of touching the earth
called a boomy sparsha mudra and this is
a representation of the moment of the
Buddha's enlightenment and surrounding
the central figure then is this great
narrative from the story of the Buddha's
previous life as Prince vasant era so
the judge ago stories were were very
important
form of Buddhist literature that
described the Buddha's past lives they
were often written in the form of
morality tales which describe a
particular kind of virtue that the
Buddha had to practice in a past life in
order to eventually become the Buddha
himself and the Buddha the center story
then was one of the most important of
these Jatakas stories in Tibet where it
was not only recorded in texts but it
was also performed in stage plays and
was widely widely beloved across to bed